it worked  mclemore and brown  blazers trying to get it spaced out a  little bit  uh-oh three-pointer on its way brandon  williams his first made three of his  career  the undrafted rookie out of arizona  i don't think he's a threat to catch  curry oh i don't know  inside he only has  3083 to go  he's right on his tail  are we keeping oh we're keeping a marker  yeah it's okay he's there three thousand  eighty four to one  but you can't get to three thousand  eighty four you gotta start with one  unless you get one and  that's gotta be a great feeling for him  brandon williams  getting a chance on a ten day contract  lost the handle turns it over  curry pushes  thompson in the corner he bobbled it  sidestep  down it goes  nelly did he bobble it but he understood  johnson was still going to recover two